if covet doesn't happen does he get
reelected yes why well because his
followers don't care about policy I
interview them all the time and I say
followers don't care about power they
don't care about achievements they care
about Hillary bad Hillary Marxist
Hillary socialists I think Hillary's
good
did I say that no I'm asking you oh no
uh I don't think Hillary was a good
candidate and she's she's to my right
um no I don't think Hillary's good but I
thought she was better than Trump she's
to your right she's to my right yeah
Hillary is a very moderate conservative
Democrat yeah your world yeah yeah good
I mean give me a left-wing Hillary
policy like a really left-wing Hillary
policy
you're saying you would much rather have
a Hillary than a trump I would rather
okay so go back much rather I don't know
so so go back to he gets reelected why
because his uh uh voters could care less
about policies that's what you're saying
fine